[Music]
[Applause]
oh look who's a host
Super Bowl champ ESPN NFL analyst Ryan
Clark just been named the new host of
inside the NFL no longer an analyst he's
a host
all right so uh there's a little bit
different approach to that that you're
used to asking being asked questions now
you have to ask questions
yeah I think uh you know I have a
podcast called the pivot and we've had
an opportunity to you know sit down with
everyone from Mike Tomlin to the Rock to
Kevin Hart all of these young athletes
who are doing amazing things and so I've
gotten some of those reps but what's
exciting about the challenge is actually
quarterbacking an entire show you know
whether it's been having opportunities
to watch you do it or sitting with Laura
Rutledge Mike Greenberg Scott Van Pelt
I've always been fascinated with that
part of the business and I think even
more than anything it's being an analyst
being looked at in that box for so long
throughout my career and now I'm having
an opportunity to do something different
I'm excited about that
so uh the analyst you got Channing
Crowder
Jay Cutler
Chad Ochocinco
and Chris Long
yep
do you have an issue with any of these
guys when you played
uh I don't think anybody ever liked it
so I don't really know if that's a
specific question for me it's freaking
Jay Cutler wait wait no no why did why
is it nobody likes Jay Cutler
you know Jay Cutler had this uh you know
I know you just talked about your
podcast that you had to cut up so let me
choose my words wisely Jay Cutler just
had this epic demeanor it was about
whatever team he was playing on and no
one else and I think that's always
different for a quarterback because a
lot of times quarterbacks try to get
along with the other teams and
quarterbacks don't really talk a lot of
trash or have certain personas because
they know they're the hunted inside the
pocket and Jay didn't care about that
and so when you ran up on a quarterback
who had a sort of defensive demeanor
about himself this me against the world
thing it's kind of off-putting and you
want to go at that dude you want to get
at him and the way that he answered
questions sort of this quiet arrogance
he had I don't think it was something
that many of us defensive players love
and so we've had rehearsal already and I
was very aware of that I I felt that
feeling but once he sat down man started
to spit his knowledge tell his stories
from his perspective you know you just
saw how good he could be at the job and
it's good to have somebody on the panel
who has sort of that demeanor to bring
that side to the show
but how many quarterbacks did you
encounter who had that attitude that if
you you know came up on them they were
gonna they were gonna say something back
they were going to engage with you Jay
Cutler is not the only guy to do that
well Philip Rivers did it but Philip
Rivers did it in an entirely different
way you know we're talking about a man
with 27 kids right Dan so you so you're
gonna need to let some things out when
you get on the football field but Phil
was the guy that talked Tom was always
super cool Peyton Manning always
extremely nice like those dudes just
wanted to go out and beat the brakes off
of you when it came to the field but
they weren't the type to talk they
weren't the type that that came at you
Jake Jay Cutler actually ran over a
teammate of mine when he played for
Chicago a guy named Robert Golden and we
never let him live it down and it was so
funny I brought it up to Jay when I saw
him he's like man you know now looking
back on it I actually feel bad he's like
I know what it is for a DB to get ran
over by a quarterback but now Jay super
cool man I'm excited to work with him uh
Ojo is always Ojo he already tried to
buy the entire crew McDonald's the last
time uh that we were together channing's
going to say whatever and I mean Chris
just just has a legacy in the lineage in
this league both on the field and off
that we're excited to tap into as well
talking to Ryan Clark the new host of
inside the NFL makes it CW debut next
Tuesday at 8 Eastern and uh they'll have
some NFL films mic'd up sounds from the
game included in that all right let's go
around the league a couple of things
here Joe burrow why no contract
you know I don't really know uh
Cincinnati has kind of been notoriously
Frugal if we're going to use uh that
word but it can't be because of the calf
injury all he's done is one when healthy
in this league a Super Bowl an AFC
Championship the last two years so it's
really a confusing thing but you have to
look at Joe burrow also has the same
agent as Nick Bosa right both of these
men deserving of new contracts neither
of those been having new contracts so
you don't know if there's something
going on there where they just can't
figure out a monetary value that makes
sense to both team and player
yeah you know people didn't get caught
up in Chris Jones and Bosa holding out
they were caught up in the running back
story like all the poor running backs
now not that Bosa and Jones aren't going
to get paid and they're going to get
paid a whole lot more but when you think
of the success of the Kansas City Chiefs
I can think Andy Reid Patrick Mahomes or
Patrick Mahomes Andy Reid and then I
probably go to Chris Jones I know
Kelsey's spectacular but on the
defensive side of the ball Chris Jones
is really real and aside from Aaron
Donald is probably the best defensive
tackle second best defensive tackle in
the game is he going to get paid by
Kansas City
yeah I believe he'll get paid by Kansas
City but we all know what happens right
Chris Jones even though we are saying
he's the second best tackle and I think
that's widely agreed to Chris Jones
thinks he's the best tackle right like
these dudes don't sit around in the
house and like man I'm really good but
that Aaron Donald is just a little bit
better do you think Chris thinks he's
better than Aaron Donald
100 okay and if and if he doesn't if he
does it then he's not the person and
player I think he is no there was a time
where that was unquestionably Aaron
Donald and you couldn't say that but
this is the Chris Jones that led his
defense to a Super Bowl this is the
Chris Jones that is important to his
team's defense as the best quarterback
in the world Patrick Mahomes is
important to their offense and when you
carry a team the way that he did up
front for the Kansas City Chiefs he I
bet this day he's not asking to be paid
less than Aaron Donald he's not just
accepting that he should be paid less
than Aaron Donald and he's going to be
in search of that money which he should
and you're right the focus is not on the
Chris Jones and the Nick Bosa hold out
because we've seen so many pass rushers
get paid already the reason it was a
running back thing is because it was a
group of them that we considered Elite
that weren't able to come to terms on
long-term contracts with their current
teams when do you make your Super Bowl
pick
whoa I hate making it before the season
right and you know this you're you're in
the business it's it's good conversation
it's conversation you need when games
aren't being played but hell I don't
know like I can be honest with you you
know then like if you look at it you say
the Philadelphia Eagles are Prime in the
NFC we've seen the best quarterbacks
either go to the Jets or retire and now
Jayla hurt sits along at the top you
look at what they did defensively
especially in the draft with a guy like
Jalen Carter earlier you say okay you
can replace some of those people that
love Philadelphia should be in it nobody
ever wants to bet against the Kansas
City Chiefs but here's my Ryan Clark
kind of I guess Off the Wall picks I
would think the Baltimore Ravens and the
Dallas Cowboys those would be my teams
if we're gonna step away from what we
always believe from thinking that
Seasons just carry over I believe that
both of those teams have played if they
played to the top of their potential
should be in the AFC NFC Championship
and can very well be in the Super Bowl
so
why is Dak Prescott a lightning rod if
Dak Prescott played on another team
would he get anywhere near this
attention
absolutely not
absolutely not Dak Prescott I don't
think Dak Prescott's play calls for this
attention either negatively or
positively uh I don't think that
Prescott's personality calls for this
sort of attention either negatively or
positively but he plays for the Dallas
Cowboys he plays for a team that when
their quarterback struggles a little bit
the year before their quarterback is
working on a new contract or needs a new
contract because his stat his cap hit is
60 million they go get a former first
first round pick who was picked third
overall that puts you back into the
conversation and also think about like
I'm smart enough now to know after
complaining on get up every Monday
morning and I don't want to talk about
the Dallas Cowboys they rape apparently
and people listen and people care and
they are America's team and when all of
those things go into those ingredients
and you're the quarterback of that team
and you can't get out of the divisional
round of the playoffs people are going
to talk about it but help me understand
this and I I know the answer but you go
into a show are you talking about the
Cowboys because they weren't being
talked about or because you know you're
going to get clicks and therefore are
you bypassing other stories that should
be talked about or more important
I think it depends on the show you're on
I think I think if a show is like Monday
morning with get up with green yeah I
think yeah sometimes you do pass it up I
think sometimes you do pass up some
stories that you personally would want
to talk about as a football analyst
stories that you personally are tapped
into or you find extremely interesting
and you know we've worked our way into
talking about those stories in order to
build viewerships about those teams in
order to get those fan bases engaged but
I think Dallas is is always a story
Dallas always finds a way
to be relevant but the fact that people
want to see it makes it something that
always moves to the top of the list as
well
yeah we love to do is you know DAC an
elite quarterback and yeah and I
understand
um I don't play to the numbers I don't
have metrics here that say you gotta
Hammer LeBron and Dallas I mean I and I
understand it when I was at ESPN we
always had to talk about Red Sox Yankees
Duke basketball like there was four or
five things that you go you got to check
the box how do we work this into the
show and it can be challenging when you
know your instincts are man we should be
talking about this wide receiver or this
defensive you know front here and we
don't always do it would you have rather
faced Brady or Aaron Rodgers
Brady
Brady and and the reason and the reason
that's a great question to ask me is I
say every day
Aaron Rodgers is the best quarterback I
ever played against I think Tom Brady is
the greatest quarterback in football
history Tom Brady was able to beat us
with his mind understand where we would
be whether it was because they had
filmed our practices and into our
signals or or if it was just Tom Brady
was that dang good
um Aaron Rodgers though when we were
really good in 2010 defensively and we
knew exactly where the ball would be
going we still couldn't beat him he
still made plays and threw footballs
into places where they just weren't
supposed to go in ways they weren't
supposed to get there and the Green Bay
Packers fans at least social media wise
has this have this big thing with me
because they think I hate Aaron Rodgers
it's actually the exact opposite I love
it and there are plays that stick out in
my mind in that Super Bowl and moments I
shared with 12 where I was like yeah bro
like he's just that dude and even in
going to practice twice this offseason
in in training camp with the New York
Jets he's still that dude he can still
do things with the football that we
haven't seen normal humans do and I
believe he's gonna have a great year
but you knew what Brady was going to do
right no no I mean you you knew where
Brady was going to go with the football
but Brady was able to adjust that based
on what we were doing if you go back
through our games against Tom Brady uh I
think it was I think it was 2000 maybe
2010 2011 I can't remember the year but
we played them in Pittsburgh and we had
drafted these young defensive backs they
were long they were fast they were
athletic we changed everything we had
ever done for one day we changed it all
and we beat the brakes off of them we we
physically abused them we dominated
their receivers and their tight ends but
it was the first time we didn't try to
beat Tom Brady here it was the first
time we didn't try to beat Tom Brady at
all what we said were we were going to
beat Rob Gronkowski we were going to
beat but he rest in peace Aaron
Hernandez we were going to beat the
receivers we weren't going to beat 12
and that's how we won the game every
time we went to a game as who we were
and did what we did the best we could
Tom Brady absolutely annihilated us
because he knew where everything was
coming and he knew what was going to be
open based on what was coming
what do you have there Paulie I got the
box score from that game and uh Ryan had
nine tackles it was a 25-17 Steelers
okay
yeah all right
so you own Tom Brady at least for one
day
no we just rented we leased it
released probably we gave him right back
he's not he gave him right back he's not
coming back Ryan you don't have to worry
about it no you don't have to worry
about it you owned Tom Brady one day one
day hey no that just makes me scared
that now he's going to want to host
Inside the NFL and take that job for me
so I'm just trying to be nice Dan uh
well good luck with this great to talk
to you congratulations
man thank you so much have a great day
that's Ryan Clark of the mothership
it'll be uh Inside the NFL makes it CW
debut next Tuesday Jay Cutler nobody
likes him Channing Crowder Chad Ocho
Cinco and Chris Long